uh this is kind of it's kind of funny
it's kind of depressing
on the one hand
the
post office as it is currently operating
is operating not as well as it could
thanks to donald trump's selection of
louis de joy to be the postmaster
general
republicans love to attack the post
office they want to damage the post
office and and the reason why is to
encourage private industry to replace it
um
so on the one hand the post office is
functioning poorly because of that and
joe biden can't just replace louis de
joy
joe biden has to wait until he can
replace members of the postal board of
governors
and they can then replace louis de joy
so there's not really that much
that that biden can do until he's able
to do that
and yet at the same time
reporters are asking gen saki and joe
biden
well
why are packages going to be delivered
more slowly around the holidays here's a
reporter yesterday asking that jen saki
exactly that question take a listen we
can go ahead let me ask that a slightly
similar different way sure
based on everything being announced
today yeah can
this administration guarantee
that holiday packages will arrive on
time
we are not the postal service or ups or
fedex we cannot guarantee what we can do
is use every lever at the federal
government disposal to reduce uh delays
to ensure that we are
addressing bottlenecks in the system
including uh ports and the the need for
them to be open longer hours so that
goods can arrive and we can continue to
press
not only workers and unions but also
companies to take as many steps as they
can to reduce these delays now there are
people who reacted and said no no the
government is the postal service it's
it's not okay
the postal service is sort of this weird
in between it's an independent business
enterprise
it's under the purview of the federal
government but joe biden doesn't control
package delivery he doesn't control what
it costs to get a tracking number he
doesn't control the logistics of uh
certified mail or anything like that
it's an independent agency of the
executive branch and the way joe biden
can influence it
is by choosing appointees by appointing
people to the board of directors who
then can decide do we want to keep
trump's postmaster general lewis to joy
or not now but my best assessment is
that on december 8th
one of trump's postal board appointees
has their term end at that point joe
biden can replace them and it's
believed that that will shift the
balance in the direction of reason and
they will remove louis de joy but it's
this crazy thing
where on the one hand
they are
ignoring the fact
that trump deliberately kneecapped the
postal service through his indirect
influence by selecting louis to joy
that's why things are the way they are
now not because of joe biden joe biden
doesn't get a pick for the board of
governors until december
but then on the other hand they're
asking jen saki can you guarantee
package delivery times no how could joe
biden guarantee that
that that's that's not the way the
postal service actually works now
whether they are
deliberately misunderstanding that in
order to ask these questions
to be salacious and provocative and
titillating or whether they genuinely
don't know that that's how it works i
don't know it would it would be a sad
commentary on the state of uh journalism
if they really don't understand
why the postal service is the way it is
right now and it's because louis de
joy's postmaster general
he's postmaster general because of the
choices that donald trump made to the
postal board of governors uh joe biden
will get a shot at changing that
in december
but uh yeah
it's almost like they think biden's
deciding we're gonna slow down package
delivery the way trump slowed down
testing they seem to act as if joe biden
has control just deliver more quickly
and fix the problem i believe this will
be solved
um but it's gonna take a little bit of
time and just just pathetic questions
pathetic continued pathetic questions
from the white house press corps
one of our sponsors is cometier coffee
the world's first frozen coffee
i've been very impressed with the coffee
i've had from cometier cometeer sources
their beans from some of the world's
best locally owned specialty roasters
and the cometeer team has developed
their own way of protecting the
freshness and aroma of the coffee by
taking its concentrated liquid form and
flash freezing it so it keeps those
original flavors and nuances comets here
comes to you frozen you just add hot
water or for iced coffee you just melt
it you can use it to make a ton of
different hot and cold coffee drinks the
way they lock in the flavor like this
you really can taste it it tastes fresh
i've been getting a ton of enjoyment out
of cometier they've got a great variety
of coffees it's delicious the way you
make it is super convenient and you'll
get twenty dollars off when you go to
cometier.com
pacman the link is underneath this video